Hey youtubers it’s charlie and since his
last vow left us with so many big questions
I wanted to do another Q&A video.
The good news is that they’ve already started
working on series 4 and they know where things
are headed in series 5.
So there will be plenty more sherlock coming
in the next couple of years.
Also heads up, I’m going to be doing weekly
Musketeers videos starting sunday.
It stars peter capaldi from doctor who.
So it’s going to be a lot of fun.
Just like my episode 2 Q&A I picked 20 of
your questions.
Since this is mostly just an episode 3 video
I’m holding all your series 4 questions
for a different Q&A later this week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Careful for spoilers for episode 3 in case
you haven’t seen the episode yet.
Mind palace time, let’s go.
Question number 1 - Chaos Thao asks, were
janine and sherlock just using each other
or did she believe sherlock’s lies?
She sold their stories to the tabloids and
made a bunch of money, so I think she didn’t
know sherlock was lying to her.
She also disabled his morphine, just out of
spite.
Question 2 - Stephanie Vicente asks, did sherlock
know that magnussen was CAM from the wedding
telegraph before he learned mary’s secret?
No, he probably didn’t figure it out until
after he landed in the hospital and started
piecing together mary’s secret.
Question 3 - Fangirl 1502 asks what is up
with everyone talking about a third holmes
brother?
So mycroft has this line during the christmas
scenes where he refers to the “other one”.
He could have just been referring to the dog,
but a lot of people think he was talking about
another holmes brother.
If he was talking about another brother it
would imply that he is died at some point
in their past.
Question 4 - Ivy He Asks, could you rank all
favorite sherlock episodes?
Right now I’d say in order of most favorite
to least, scandal, sign of three, Reichenbach,
great game, last vow, empty hearse, study
in pink, baskerville and blind banker.
Question 5 - Gvantsa Basilia asks do you think
Moriarty is still alive?
yes and no.
The person you saw shoot himself on the rooftop
in Reichenbach is dead.
I’m saving a lot of the moriarty talk for
my series 4 video this week.
Question 6 - Filip Ratkovic asks what was
your funniest moment?
I would say when sherlock and mycroft got
caught smoking by their mother.
Question 7 - Brooke Hester asks, did you think
the goodbye scene was too cold?
I think that Watson was ready to get on with
his life.
He’d already made peace with mary’s deception,
so he wasn’t holding on to any more anger.
And he got a proper goodbye this time.
He didn’t have to watch sherlock fall out
of the plane or anything.
And remember that they’re classic british
characters, which means that they wouldn’t
show a lot of outward emotion.
That’s why the hug during the wedding was
such a huge deal.
Question 8 - Caroline guess asks How do you
think they will bring moriarty back?
I actually have a very detailed theory I want
to save for my series 4 video, all I say now
is that “There is another skywalker”.
If you get my meaning.
Question 9 - michaelmerc99 asks who’s a
better villain, moriarty or magnussen
I liked Andrew Scott’s performance more,
but if this were real life Magnussen would
be the more successful villain.
Even mycroft says that he protecting him just
because he’s been useful to the government
in the past and he never goes after anyone
to important.
Question 10 - Blake Hutton asks do you think
sherlock being a murderer got out or do you
think the government covered it up?
I definitely think the government covered
it up.
Remember that line of mycroft’s, england
will always need sherlock holmes.
So they dealt with it by sending him on that
really dangerous mission before the events
of the post credits scene happened.
Question 11 - Cam Edwards asks did you expect
sherlock to do what he did at the end?
how else could he have resolved the plot?
I was surprised by what happened.
But right before he did it he said high functioning
sociopath, so I think that all of that emotion
and gushiness we saw from him in the first
two episodes was a facade.
He was fulfilling his “last vow” the best
way he could think of.
The only alternative would have been to permanently
incapacitate magnussen so that they could
find a way to control the cybernetic implants
in his body.
Question 12 - Sinup 34 asks do you think we’ll
ever learn what Augustus had on mary?
No, I don’t think we were meant to.
That’s what the burning of that hard drive
was all about.
And really it was just all the people she
had killed and awful things she’d done while
she was working as a freelance hitman.
Question 13 - Sarah Zmnia asks, how are magnussen
and moriarty connected.
Is one controlling the other?
Just in the context of series 1 through three,
they’re just fellow business men.
Magnussen probably knows about everything
moriarty ever did and moriarty probably had
snipers on magnussen all the time.
But, Events during series 4 might change the
way we perceive their relationship.
Question 14 - Olivia Obembe asks why do you
think the people in sherlock’s mind palace
during the middle of the episode were there?
The mind palace summons the most relevant
person for what sherlock needs.
Since molly was his most trusted medical professional,
she was the one that helped him first.
Mycroft was kind of like purgatory, the transitional
state before he finally went into the land
of the dead.
Moriarty was there to help him survive the
pain.
He was so intense and seemed to thrive.
So the mind palace conjured him up to learn
how he did it.
Question 15 - Chelsea Parkin asks why did
magnussen mention mary’s family in the letter
at her wedding?
He had probably been blackmailing mary her
whole life, so he knew she had no real family.
He was just fucking with her like when he
was flicking watson’s eye.
Question 16 - XBloodyDesiresX asks what do
you think about sherlock being a murderer
now?
I think it’s totally within the character
to do something like that.
Remember he’s a high functioning sociopath.
So what’s the best way to get rid of all
those secrets when they only exist in magnussen.
Just delete the hard drive.
With a bullet.
Question 17 - Ambre Trongnez asks could you
explain the 221B door that flashed during
sherlock’s big mind palace sequence?
That was just a representation of his life.
The whole sequence was him trying to come
back to life.
221B Baker street is a visual representation
of his life.
Question 18 - Ether asks, does sherlock use
his patches to cover up a habit?
Jeanine had a right hand ring as do all the
clown gang members, do they all mean the same
thing?
I always imagine sherlock having tons of patches
everywhere, but if you’re talking about
using patches to cover up a heroin habit then
no I don’t think so.
I think you were implying that he’d had
a habit this whole time, not just in this
episode.
I don’t think that was the case, but I do
think he was high when molly slapped him.
And the rings, that’s an awesome observation.
We didn’t see much of the clown gang after
episode 2, so it’s possible that all those
rings are connected to something that will
manifest during series 4.
At least that’s what I’m hoping.
Question 19 - Vica Otrubina asks is sherlock
not a virgin anymore?
Even though he was in that drug den for a
month it’s kind of implied he went back
and forth to 221B Baker street to be with
Janine.
So yes, I do think they had sex.
The real question is was he high while they
were doing it.
and question 20 last one - Megafluffz was
sherlock high at the beginning of the episode?
He bends the truth a lot, but I think they
implied that he was.
At least a little.
I don’t think he would have actually gone
nutters.
He was still working magnussen’s case the
whole time.
He kind of confesses to mycroft that he was
high, but that he doesn’t keep drugs around
baker street.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting your
questions.
sorry I couldn’t answer them all.
Like I said, I’m saving a lot of the post-credits
questions for my series 4 video.
be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’m going to try and post it tomorrow night
when I post my episode 3 breakdown.
But wednesday at the latest.
I’ll also probably do a series 4 q and a
after that video too.
Don’t forget, this sunday I’m also starting
weekly musketeers videos.
starring peter capaldi.
It’s going to be a lot of fun.
Right now click here for my episode 3 review
and click here for my review of episode 2.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow!